after copying over the assets updating
launcher icon in the Android manifest
and adding the helper methods to the
utility class we need to modify the
detail fragment and forecast adapter
classes in the detail fragment class in
the onload finish method we read the
weather condition code from the cursor
then we pass it into the utility helper
method to get the colored icon for
setting onto the image view in the
detail fragment onload finished method
we read the weather condition code from
the cursor then we pass this into the
utility helper method to get the
resource ID for the colored icon in
order to set it onto the image view the
forecast adapter changed a little
trickier because we want to use a
colored icon for the today layout and we
want to use a grey icon for the other
days in order to distinguish between the
two we call get item view type given the
current cursor position if the view type
is today then we get the weather
condition code from the cursor then we
get the resource ID for the colored
image from the helper method and then we
set that on to the image view if the
view type is for a future day then we
read the weather condition code from the
cursor then we pass it into the helper
method to get the resource ID for the
grey icon and then we set that on to the
image view if you've previously
hard-coded an image into the layout then
you should remove that value now
otherwise on app launch it will load up
the placeholder image and then flash to
the actual icon now that the wireframe
implementation for the phone UI is
pretty much complete let's look at the
tablet UI